hello everyone and Welcome to our
coverage of the 2023 national
championships round five was amazing
round six is shaping up as another
highly combative intense round but we
have a special guest in studio Shannon
Bailey of the World Chess Hall of Fame
Shannon welcome
again I'm so happy to have you here wow
so many great exhibits in the musical
series especially yes so we have this
wonderful music series at the hall of
fame which we've had for years they sell
out almost every single time we've got
one get a seat no one that focuses a lot
on Regional bands and then one that kind
of goes into more of like a
classical uh kind of genre we work a lot
with the symphony and other types of
classical musicians so it's a little
something for everybody I know that you
do a lot of exhibition so take take us
back a little bit why did you decide to
do chess and uh music yeah so we have an
exh exhibit right now called sound moves
where music meets chess and that was
curated by me and my husband Bradley
Bailey who's a professor at St Louis
University and is an art and chess
scholar as well and he's also a huge fan
of music so we were kind of looking at
all these great music connections that
we have and that we celebrate our music
and so we thought you know let's do a
show about Chess and music well there's
a big correlation when I think about uh
top players Mark Ty off comes
immediately to featured in the
porish I think gotsky is really a
classical pianist so music and chess
definitely huge connections there are so
many pieces in this show and it we just
scratched the surface so you know we
could have looked at it it just as like
people that used uh musicians who used
chess on their album covers that could
have been an entire show uh chess
players that play music music musicians
that play chess but we just kind of
threw it all in there and it's a nice
little survey of stuff so there's a
little something for everybody every Bud
upcoming yeah so this uh weekend we have
uh Marina toy is coming in and she is
amazing she uh designed costumes that
Katie Perry's team wore in the Super
Bowl halftime show in 2015 it's amazing
I visited Hall of Fame and with some of
my students uh at the chess games and
they just love the costumes so great so
she also did many costumes for the mass
singer uh costumes for uh I said Katy
Perry uh Ariana Grande Taylor Swift and
she grew up playing chess in Russia so
she has this great chess connection and
and I don't think she even realized how
much she was putting chess into her work
until we contacted her and started
pointing it all out so we're really
excited that's a free event Saturday
it's at was you yes on the 14th 3 p.m.
visit our website for more information
about that um we'd love to see people
there you're going to get to play chess
with her and you get to hear about her
work especially what she did with the
Super Bowl halftime show wow it's
amazing you know and chess is becoming
so mainstream a lot of famous people are
now playing chess or posing with chess
uh so can you tell us about more
musicians that are currently U kind of
incorporating chess into their work yeah
so we worked at Julian Castle blanc's
team who was in The Strokes and he has
chess all over his albums and uh he wore
a jacket in a music video with a
chessboard on the back and uh we hope to
have him here in St Louis we have tons
of photos of people playing chess some
of them are stage cuz you you know how
you can tell set up the king of the
the which I know you guys love to point
out but there are some people you know
who really are you know playing chess in
them a lot of jazz musicians like Dizzy
Gillespie and count basy um so it's fun
to see them sitting down and playing
chest these beautiful photographs and
then we've got you know the signed copy
of the Queen's Gambit score um we worked
with the mun for Chess the musical this
summer which was such a beautiful
collabor
that was really freshh fresh in my mind
and we went backstage I actually went to
see it twice I saw three times I saw
three times my daughter and I saw three
times and if there would have been
another show we would have seen it and
we got to meet the cast and they were
just fantastic musicians amazing people
and they were telling us how stressed
they were they were about actually
getting the the chess part of that
musical correct exactly they did such a
good job though yeah so it's been fun
World Chess Hall of Fame just had a huge
collection we had Sal Mata came on he
was a president of the Marshall chess
trust boxes of stuff went to the World
Chess Hall of Fame so essentially your
Fisher collection's getting bigger stuff
and I um had brunch with s the other day
and he was telling me about playing
Bobby as a kid right and I said you have
to write all this down you have to turn
this into an article or a book or
something because this is firsthand
accounts of their relationship and both
being taught by Jack Collins and um yeah
as you can tell I love my job because I
get to meet the coolest people isn't it
and you Boris basy Jr yes that was a
magical time too yeah right and that's
all on the World Chess Hall of Fame
website too that you can see a video of
him um talking about his father and uh
his relationship with Bobby and we did
that huge show last year celebrating the
50th anniversary of the 1972 world
championship and it was much of a
celebration of Boris as it was Bobby
absolutely two incredible men uh Boris
basy was a stand-up human being and his
you know meeting his son was a great
honor you know I'm always so impressed
to go to Chess Hall of Fame and see all
that material and how much you guys know
about chess players I feel like I know
nothing when I'm there because they know
so much about the personal life I
remember reading some of the letters
that Bobby Fisher wrote to Boris basy I
mean you could see that friendship there
for me it was fantastic well we're
really proud to do a wide array of
exhibitions to try to you know get you
really excited about it that are in it
but then bringing in new audiences of
people who might just like music or just
like science or fashion we just we want
to bring everybody in and teach them how
great chess is speaking of new audiences
too one of my favorite exhibitions I'll
surprise you with this one was chess and
Comics oh I love you had all of these
comic book now when I was a kid you know
the Hulk Thor and the greatest Silver
Surfer Silver Surfer I mean he was like
the greatest uh you know had the cosmic
uh energy uh going but that was a
marvelous exhibit on all the kids so I
have to say what you're going to learn
is these exhibitions are a Bailey Family
Affair so my my daughter Mina was little
at the time she was obsessed with
superheroes and I thought I've got some
comic books we've got some chess sets
that deal with superheroes so I put that
together basically as like a gift to her
and that you know ended up being you
know such a fun fun show I mean we had
over aund comics hanging up and that was
just scratching the surface so another
thing you can tell is we've got a great
permanent collection and you know one
thing that I one show that I regret of
missing and I know a lot of people keep
reminding how amazing it was it was I
think called the fire on the board you
play you play with cand your husband was
my opponent the pictures look amazing
and I know the players just loved it how
how you play with bring back we will
bring it back we almost brought it back
last summer um but we're trying to find
a good time to do that and that is Glen
Kyo is the artist and you literally play
with burning candles I'm definitely
coming for that you will be invited for
sure so yeah I mean we've got GTO
vanderver coming back to the chess piano
that's in the show that'll be something
going on in January so a little
something for everybody Shannon thank
you so much for coming thank you for
joining us it's always a great pleasure
thank you for what you do for chess
because you know it's not just the games
it's really the players and learning
about them to learn about the chess
culture so thank you absolutely thank
you for having me thank you Shannon and
once again our standings we're going to
start with a ladyes casee